uh next you know yesterday we released
an important interview Paula Scanlon
appeared in uh she appeared in what is a
woman her name's Paula Scanlon and she's
a teammate of Leah Thomas who's the male
UPenn swimmer who competed against women
and uh you might not recognize the name
from the film because she wasn't named
in the film she appeared in the film
anonymously her face was blacked out her
voice was changed
but then she reached out to us a few
weeks ago and she said she wanted to go
public and it just so happened that she
reached out to us she didn't know that
we were planning on releasing what is a
woman on Twitter she didn't know about
all the things we had planned
um and so this all kind of worked out
she just happened to reach out to us at
the exact same moment we were planning
all of this and um and she said she
wanted to go public she wanted to put
her face a name with it and really speak
out in a more visible way so we were of
course happy to have her back talk to
her again which we did and um you can
find the whole interview on Twitter and
I think on YouTube until YouTube takes
it down
whole conversation is is worth listening
to but I want to play this one part for
you okay
Paula talks about how the university
would shut down dissent from the real
women on the team
and so because many of us have wondered
you know when these men are invading
women's sports why aren't the women on
the teams speaking out more uh what are
they saying behind the scenes there's no
way they're okay with this how could
they be okay with it well I asked her
about that and she she she talks about
it in some detail
um and she says that they had the
university had a meeting
where they sat all the girls down and
Leah Thomas was not at
the meeting okay he wasn't there
and but they sat everyone down they
brought in the activists from the campus
LGBT Center
and they basically told all the girls to
fall in line
and also offered them psychological
counseling
to help heal their mental problems that
would cause them to object in the first
place
okay so this is there was a real
campaign of intimidation coercion and
this sort of psychological manipulation
and gaslighting that went on to make the
girls on the team feel crazy for not
being okay with having a naked man in
the locker room or having their
opportunities stolen from them by a man
competing on the team
and that in that campaign was apparently
very effective
so um here she is talking a little bit
about that listen
so prior to that meeting I would have
one-on-one conversations with pretty
much everyone on the team
say hey like you know that I don't think
this is right yeah I don't think it's
right either
um another teammate actually said to me
I think Leah's record should have an
asterisk or someone said I think Leah
should compete exhibition or you know I
don't think this is going to go on for
much longer like someone's going to step
in and end this and I have these
conversations with so many of my
teammates I would say most people on the
team had this opinion and then after
that meeting they really scared us it
was scary and I and I was petrified I
went home that night and I called my
brother on the phone and I said can I
even talk about this with you like am I
is there something wrong with me for
thinking that this is wrong whatever it
worked the university wanted us to be
quiet and they did it in a very
effective way like they continue to just
tell us that our opinions were wrong and
that if we had an issue with it we were
the problem and it's frightening and
your future job is on the line and
everything else you want to accomplish
so of course it worked and then after
that point no one would talk about it
anymore like if they effectively you
know silenced us even within talking to
each other
uh she she also tells and and again you
can go Twitter or YouTube and find the
interview
um it's about I think about 30 minutes
long
the whole story is worth here and
there's there's a lot more there about
what they did to these to these uh to
these women
um she gives one specific example of a
teammate of hers who was very against
this and she said hey I'm going to go in
and uh I'm gonna talk to someone I'm
gonna have a meeting with the
administration and speak up
and she did
and then she came back and it was like
Invasion of the Body Snatchers it was
she she came back and she said well this
is actually a really good thing and it's
it's really beautiful and Powerful that
Leah is here
change just like that on a dime
the CEO of innovation refunds and
getrefunds.com has been on TV explaining
how they've helped so many small
businesses with their ERC tax refunds
they've completed thousands of returns
for different kinds of businesses
including over 700 million dollars for
construction companies and over 200
million dollars in restaurants bars and
hotels Innovation refunds has hundreds
of five-star trust pilot in Google
reviews and is certified with the Better
Business Bureau in just eight minutes
you can easily start the process on
getrefunds.com you can be on your way to
receiving up to twenty six thousand
dollars per employee the RC tax credit
is not a loan it's a refund of your
already paid tax is designed to let the
business owner direct the money into
anything the business needs to grow it's
money that you can use to improve your
business however you see fit so go to
getrefunds.com to start the process
there's no upfront charge there's uh you
know they don't get paid unless you get
paid it's simple as that Innovation
refunds it's already helped clients
claim over five billion dollars in
payroll tax refunds through the ERC and
they may be able to help your business
too so go to getrefunds.com or download
the app from the app store today that's
getrefunds.com today
um but what really what really struck me
I remember this the first time we talked
to Paula back for the interview
that and she even she even admits that
she herself began questioning her own
judgment and Common Sense
she started to think well am I am I
wrong here as everyone around me is
affirming it and all the authority
figures are affirm again the school is
and I look around on campus it's all
affirming it and saying this is good and
so am I am I the crazy one
now you might hear that and think well
you have to be very weak-minded to
question
but no not not at all this is when this
is the psychological impact of people
being made to feel isolated
um
and and you know when when the messaging
all around you is like this is okay this
is good this is okay this is good
and they're beating you over the head
with it
eventually for it starts to break down
your psychological defenses
um and then on top of it because she
also talks about this in the interview
I think this is one of the reasons why
this sort of thing is especially
effective on women is that if you're if
you if you are a you know an empathetic
person and
you know you care about other people you
wanted the people to feel good and be
happy and all that
not only are they manipulating you and
they're intimidating you and coercing
you and they're gaslighting you but
they're also playing on that they're
taking advantage and exploiting that
they're taking and it's so Sinister
because they're taking something that's
good about you which is that your
compassion and you're empathetic and you
care about people and you don't want to
hurt people's feelings and that's a good
thing and they're turning it against you
um
by telling you that well look if you
really care about people and you want
and you don't want to hurt their
feelings then you should go along with
this and if you don't go along with this
this person's going to be uh they might
kill themselves if you don't go along
with it
so that's that's the kind of environment
that people are are put in
but most of all and I and I hear this
wasn't just from Paula it was just in
one interview I hear this all the time
from people
that most of all what the left does on
really on any issue but especially on
this one
is they want you to feel like you're
alone they want you to feel isolated
so you understand you know right from
wrong you have common sense
but they want you to feel like you're
you're the only one who feels the way
that you do
everyone else around you
is on the same page
and you're the one person who's
questioning this
so what you think is common sense must
not be if it was common sense why isn't
it's called common for a reason should
be shared by everybody
um
and that's and that's also why they are
desperate to shut down anyone who talks
about this
you know it's why they want to shut down
what is a woman all the de-platforming
everything
main reason they're doing that
is because it breaks the illusion
that you're alone
and uh and that's what they're most
terrified of
if you'd like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
Walsh Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed